(upbeat music)
- I, uh, often do look at a
pile of stuff at work
and think: “Maybe I should
stick that on my face.”
(upbeat music)
The Bob Bugs Project started
with just my Instagram account,
and I started using it for an art diary.
I got an idea.
Every day I disguise myself in some way.
Day 363.
Now for a creative breakthrough.
(glass shattering)
My name is Michael Gump.
I am an art director and a prop master
for crazy TV shows,
and I'm also known as Bob Bugs.
The Master of Disguise Project
is partly to build creative strength
or maybe to exorcise creative demons
in a way that's not just at my job
but also for my own evil wishes.
You look at the picture,
it maybe seems like it
took a million years.
I'm usually like, "I gotta get this done.
I gotta get to bed."
So, I just get my stuff
and then set it all up
and then.
I usually, like, you know, start with this area
and then work my way out
and then it'll be like.
People ask me all the time like:
“How many people do you
have to help you with that?”
Usually nobody.
- [Interviewer] Does it hurt?
- One that stands out in my mind
was kind of like what am I doing?
I was putting clothespins on my face,
and so I started sticking them on there
and then I kind of panicked a little bit
and I took them all off
and I was like, "Okay."
And then I was like, "Okay,
this is gonna be fine."
And then I put them all back on.
You get used to discomfort pretty fast,
but I'm concerned
that it's definitely not
that good for my skin.
- [Interviewer] Do you have a favorite?
- I do have a special place in my heart
for that one that's like a green Mr. T
because I just think it's funny,
like Mr. Green T I call it.
It's been a kind of exhausting
process in some ways.
I usually only get like maybe
three hours of sleep a night.
The discovery of the project
and part of the point of the project
is that you don't always know what's good.
So on the days that I really feel tired
and I don't really want to do it,
I don't really have a good idea,
sometimes those projects come out better
than the ones that I'm
really excited about.
What's next?
We'll have to wait and see.